if we look at the most common types of
analysis of variance we distinguish
between the one factor and the two
factor analysis of variance and on the
other hand the analysis of variance
without repeated measures and with
repeated measures what is the difference
between single factorial and 2 factorial
let's start with the question of what a
factor actually is
a factor is for example the gender of a
person with the characteristics male and
female or
the form of therapy used for a disease
with therapy a b and c
or it could be the field of study with
for example medicine business
administration psychology and math
in the case of analysis of variance a
factor is therefore a categorical
variable you use an analysis of variance
whenever you want to test whether these
categories have an influence on the
so-called dependent variable for example
you could test whether gender has an
influence on salary whether the therapy
has an influence on the blood pressure
or
whether the field of study has an
influence on the duration of study
celery blood pressure and study duration
are then the dependent variables in all
these cases you can now check whether
the factor has an influence on the
dependent variable since you only have
one factor in these cases
you could use a single factor analysis
of variance you're right if you say well
in the first case we have a variable
with only two categories
so of course we could use the t-test for
independent samples as well
now of course you may say but i have
another categorical variable that may
also have an effect on the dependent
variable and i want to include that
variable as well
maybe you would also like to know if in
addition to gender the highest level of
education has an impact on salary
or in addition to the form of therapy
maybe you would also like to include
gender
or in the third case you would also like
to know whether in addition to the field
of study the university attended also
has an influence on the length of study
now in these cases you would not have
one factor but two factors in each case
and since you now have two factors you
use the two factor analysis of variance
with the help of the two factor analysis
of variance you can now answer three
things
once whether the first factor has an
influence on the dependent variable
wants whether the second factor has an
influence on a dependent variable and
then you can also make a statement
whether there is a so-called interaction
effect between the two factors therefore
in the case of single factor analysis of
variance we have one factor from which
we create the groups in the case of the
two factor analysis of variance the
group results from the combination of
the expression of the two factors
if we have a factor or variable with
three expressions and one with two
expressions we get a total of six groups
that we want to compare
i hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time